early on in your life you were in a  Rolling Stones cover band yeah Wow yeah  you were the lead singer I was we were  called a shot in the dark we caught  ourselves a [ __ ] in the dark  cuz we suck so badly what would you go  to song when you were mature brown sugar  I want to hear you sing brown sugar here  you go  go cold slave ship bound for cotton  fields sold in the market down in New  Orleans good I told slave and knows he's  doing all right  here I'm with the Wham and just around  midnight up brown sugar how come you  taste so good  check out the dancing [ __ ] Wow Wow sugar  just like a younger should I had enough  of that what really I was fine am i  turning you on yeah